when you show somebody a game and you
see them smile their face light up
because it's something that you made
that feeling is really incredible game
Academy is where I learned the skills to
do that the high school game Academy is
a six-week program during the
pre-college Carnegie Mellon summer I
came to this program so that I would
better see if this was what I wanted for
my future I was really interested in
video game design and like art and
entertainment it seemed like it was
gonna give us a good sense of what the
actual game industry might be like it's
like sharpening each talent you have
I've met a lot of people who share my
interests and passions that they gave me
from a wide variety of different
backgrounds the curriculum is based on
the curriculum of the graduate program
at the entertainment Technology Center
which combines artists and technicians
together to build a number of games over
the course making a game requires a lot
and at game Academy I learned how to
work with people of different
disciplines in order to achieve the
greater goal of creating a game we're
working on a game called Eon which is
basically a puzzle platformer that duels
it on the mechanic of time so there's me
I'm an artist Audrey she is our producer
and also another artist Rohan
he's our sound designer cushaw who is
one of our programmers and then there's
Vivian who's our other program literally
each what each piece of work that one
person does connects to a piece of work
that the other person does in the end
everyone wants a good product to come
out and so you have to really learn to
put the team first even though we do all
have specific roles they aren't that
limiting in the sense that everybody has
a say in every part of the project
you know how much passion everybody has
put into their projects and it's really
fun to play them we also get insight
into other industries and other
processes such as sound design and music
production art and animation nowhere
else can you have such a vast amount of
technology at your disposal we get to
use like VR and we get to use like the
cave and we get to like experiment and
play with all these things they open up
the vibe room so we can play beat saver
occasionally so that's always nice by
attending this program you're gonna be
exposed to all of the different aspects
of game design
after the game Academy experience I was
said this is what I wanted to do they
come away convinced that's a first of
all can handle college and second of all
can be a contributing artistic member of
a creative team the teas and the
teachers and the directors that all
super helpful I think that the things
that I've learned here are absolutely
gonna be invaluable now I feel a lot
more prepared and I really know like
what I'm getting into
are you interested in game azan are you
interested in learning something new do
you wanna have a fun summer and I say
just go for it